après le au nord 9 lite après le au nord
disent l'avoir si venu le tour du nord
20 life honorent va nous présenter d'ici
quelques jours
la nouvelle série au nord 20 ans on a
déjà le au northern lights qui est là
j'ai déjà parlé des des modèles d'avant
il ya longtemps
aujourd'hui c'est au nord 20 lite vous
dire s'il est intéressant oui non quoi
comment bon je vais vous le présentez
vous allez voir c'est un smartphone qui
est intéressant c'est un smartphone
d'entrée milieu de gamme va dire l
entrée du milieu de gamme smartphone qui
t'as des banques qui sont quand même
plutôt pas mal
à commencer par l'écran mais avant toute
chose je vais essayer de le replacer
dans son contexte le honorera light va
se positionner en face du samsung galaxy
à 40 à savoir que notre ville ait coûte
299 euros le cac 40
259 euros en retrouvant face le huawei
p30 light et on retrouve également en
face le huawei paix smart ça fait
beaucoup de smartphones de voiture
sachant que huawei et au nord c'est la
même maison
on peut éventuellement aussi le comparer
aux chiens aux mines fse mais bon celui
ci quand même un tout petit peu plus
cher
on a donc un espèce de fight fratricide
entre trois modèles qui viennent
en gros d'une seule et grande maison
même si huawei et au nord on va dire que
ce sont exactement la même marque ça
vient quand même du même groupe donc
dans l'ensemble fait votre choix alors
aujourd'hui on va se concentrer sur le
modèle du milieu sur celui là sur le au
nord 20 light c'est un produit que
j'aime bien je trouve élégant se trouve
qu'il ya beau design qui est fait avec
un dos en verre comme ça qui est très
sympa bon ça c'est un peu classique
capteur d'empreintes digitales néanmoins
il marche très bien et déverrouille
extrêmement rapidement donc ça c'est un
point qui est plutôt bien
c'est un smartphone qui est pas très
lourd il ses 164 g prise en main on est
bien on est quand même sur un grand
écran un écran de 6,21 pouces de
diagonale c'est une dalle épaisse et du
lcd qu'avec une définition de 2340 par
1080 pixels à 415 pixels par pouce il
est intéressant l'écran et bien il n'est
pas hyper hyper hyper lumineux en
extérieur
il va être bien
mais si vous avez beaucoup de soleil et
vous risquez au bout d'un moment de
galères et de l'autre côté on essaiera
sans attendre qu'ils coûtent moins de
300 euros 299 euros on peut pas trop
trop trop lui envoyer de ce côté là je
dirais que c'est aussi un smartphone
qu'on va utiliser à demain si vous
l'utilisez humain un doigt qui va
galérer un petit peu ça c'est un petit
peu compliqué vous l'utilisez à demain
vous le tenez là vous êtes relativement
bien de toute façon dans tous ces écrans
de 6 2 pouces il ya un moment on peut
pas forcément l'utiliser une maintenant
il faut passer à des smartphones de -2 6
pouces chose très importante sur ce
smartphone lorsque vous le prenez je
trouve qu'il est un petit peu trop bleu
je vous conseille tout de suite d'aller
dans vos paramètres d'affichage d'aller
dans affichage vous allez tout de suite
dans mode des températures de couleur
normalement par défaut vous êtes en
couleurs vives couleurs vives c'est très
bleu c'est très contrastée s'est pas
forcément terrible
vous mettez en couleur normale je trouve
qu'à tendance un petit peu avoir une
espèce de couleurs un petit peu violine
bleuté venez le cas c'est d'apporter un
peu plus de jeunes ça va venir le casser
et je trouve que c'est quand même mieux
ça va venir je lire un petit peu ça va
casser un peu la lumière bleue pour moi
vous avez le meilleur résultat des
couleurs qui sont assez respectés pas
trop de lumière bleue pour moi c'est
vraiment bien par contre il ya tout qui
est pas forcément terrible c'est le
confort des yeux je cherche toujours à
l'activé mois dont vous l'activez mais
même si l'outil soit température-là
moins chaudes
vous avez une espèce de truc jaune vert
pas terrible vous pouvez strictement
rien faire si vous mettez plus chaude
c'est pas beau pour moi le confort des
yeux là dessus c'est assez raté puisque
vous dans l'eau mais ça reste 11 ea vous
tournez sur le n8 9.0.1 sur un android 9
paille ça marche c'est bien vous avez
toutes les questions de sécurité pour le
déverrouiller avec le capteur
d'empreintes digitales vous avez aussi
failli seul bloc si vous le souhaitez
vous avez de la navigation penche est si
vous le souhaitez à les respecter a
dévié sur par gestes pouvaient venir
soit ip en fin de quelque chose qui est
vraiment bien qu'ils marchent bien qu et
pratique vous allez aussi toutes les
questions d'équilibré digitales sur
notre utilisation bon deux points de vue
alors et c'est bien ce qu'on pourrait
regretter si vous ne connaissez pas ces
cas pas de tiroirs d'applications ici
donc bon certains regretteront d'autres
non dans l'absolu pour moi ça fonctionne
côté performances on n'est pas sur le
dernier soc de silicone on est sûr à
kirin 710 c'est un socle milieu de gamme
qui fonctionnera je dirais pour faire
tourner de 90% du plastor tout ce qui va
être un peu gourmand vous
est limité si vous installez par exemple
pbg là dessus vous allez mettre en
qualité graphique résolution basse ça
marchera sera pas un truc de fou
néanmoins vous pouvez faire tourner des
jeux sans problème des applications
votre instagram vos e-mails vous pouvez
regarder des vidéos ça fonctionnera qui
épaulé avec 4 gigas de ram qui lui
confère suffisamment de fluidité et 128
giga de stockage que vous pouvez monter
grâce à une carte microsd laura cela que
vous avez ici juste en soit la
possibilité d'avoir une double carte sim
double anneau sim soit une quarantaine
hocine et une carte microsd au choix
le résultat est bien que ce soit pour
jouer à des jeux vous avez suffisamment
de fluidité lorsque vous vous plantez
pas ou pour visionner des vidéos alors
vous avez si une petite encoche goutte
d'eau on la voit
vous pouvez faire le choix de rester en
format standard ou alors devenir zoomer
dans la vidéo c'est au choix
maintenant il ya un truc assez moyen
c'est l'audio vous avez du son qui est
très très très médium avec un seul
haut-parleur ici haut parleur mono
néanmoins sur ce smartphone vous avez
une prise jack et conservées en dessous
ça c'est un point qui est plutôt positif
ça vous permet de profiter d'une
meilleure qualité audio lorsque vous
jouez à des jeux vous voulez regarder
des films
vous voulez faire ce que vous voulez la
qualité quand même meilleur alors on
n'est pas serein truc qui est
complètement dingue en termes de qualité
audio mais ça vous permet quand même de
profiter d'un son qui est optimisé tout
de suite ses meilleurs le spectre est
beaucoup plus large
on récupère un peu plus de sons graves
s'est pas complètement dingue mais c'est
quand même bien meilleur au casque côté
autonomie vous tiendra une journée une
journée et demie dans le meilleur des
cas ça va dépendre une fois de plus de
votre usa que vous avez une batterie de
trois mille quatre cent millions par
heure à l'intérieur du fait qu'on n'est
pas un soc hyper performant et qu'on ait
une batterie 3400 milliards eur on
arrive à quelque chose de raisonnable
une journée pour moi vous viendrez une
journée c'est la moyenne si par contre
passé quand beaucoup de temps dessus
vous vous le sollicitez la journée vous
n'atteindrez pas ça va vraiment dépendre
de vos usages compter qu'avec ce
smartphone vous allez avoir une
autonomie d'une journée
normalement ça fonctionnera sans aucun
problème nathan se prête aussi un peu
embêtant que ce smartphone c'est que
vous avez uniquement de la recharge en
micro usb pas de recharge rapide là
dessus donc vous prévoyez le soir de
leurs charges et pour l'avoir lendemain
matin c'est bien néanmoins en cas de
coup dur
il va pas se recharger très rapidement
il faut donc anticiper ces problèmes-là
commander sur un smartphone qui est pas
très cher ya pas de certification ip sur
ce modèle
assurez-vous s'il rencontre de l'eau ces
rencontres des poussières il n'a pas
explosé une certification ipc coûte à
peu près
20 euros par modèle c'est la raison pour
laquelle sur des smartphones d'entrée et
milieu de gamme
en règle générale ils ne le font pas
certifié tout simplement pour éviter
d'augmenter le coût avec le smartphone
soit concurrentielle je vous rappelle
quand même con à 299 euros sur ce
smartphone d'ailleurs si vous intéresse
je vous ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description maintenant peau qui est
sympa là dessus vous avez un triple
capteur photo vous avez un module
principal de 24 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f 1.8 vous avez un deuxième
capteur de 8 mégapixels un grand-angle
qui ouvre à f 2.4 et vous avez d'un des
capteurs qui vous servira pour le mode
portrait pour ajouter le flou
d'arrière-plan à l'avant vous avez une
caméra de 30 2 mégapixels par défaut
vous allez regarder dans vos paramètres
sept ans résolution 12 mégapixels
c'est là vous aurez franchement les
meilleurs résultats vous pouvez monter
tout de suite en 24 mégapixels si vous
le souhaitez mais pour moi les meilleurs
résultats
vous obtiendrez comme ça dans cette
configuration en 12 mégapixels 4/3 dans
le mode vidéo par défaut et vous met en
720p hd ce que je vous conseille c'est
de monter up en full hd ou alors
carrément si vous le souhaitez en full
hd à 60 images par seconde
de toute façon la vidéo c'est pas un
truc qui est fou c'est un truc qui est
bien pour capter quelques souvenirs mais
c'est pas là dessus vous avez des images
de dengue point de vue logiciel vous
avez donc la partie photo vidéo le mode
portrait avec fameux flou d'arrière-plan
clichés nocturne alors attention c'est
pas un smartphone qui optimisé pour les
photos de nuit
vous allez voir le rendu est pas
terrible je vous les afficher dans
quelques instants le mot d'ouverture
bon ce que je vous conseille réellement
ce smartphone c'est soit le mode
portrait si vous voulez un flou
d'arrière-plan vous allez voir c'est pas
mal mais ça marche
des photos classiques et quelques vidéos
mais bon voilà c'est pas un smartphone
qui est fait pour la vidéo laissez-moi
vous montrer quelques clichés vous allez
voir le résultat est convenable est
correct c'est pas d'un accès par les
photos les plus contrastées que vous
allez avoir ça vous permet de faire
quelques souvenirs mais c'est pas un
smartphone de dingue on est de l'autre
côté un peu moins de 300 euros on peut
pas trop lui en demander
je vous laisse regarder et dites moi ce
que vous en pensez en bas aux
commentaires
c'est une affaire de famille
dans ce monde
[Musique]
en tout cas
oh
benoît yen à chaud
[Musique]
bon
oui ça
là vous voyez
cela
m
[Musique]
le terme est
m
[Musique]
oui
cole
vous l'aurez compris on est sur un
smartphone qui est pas mal qui est
correct qui est pas un smartphone deux
dunks y ait une évolution du 10 light
qui me semble intéressant si toutefois
vous voulez acheter un smartphone de la
marque au nord et vous voulez profiter
d'un écran qui est relativement bien
calibrée même si pas hyper lumineux si
vous voulez un produit qui est de bonne
facture ne voulait pas mettre trop
d'argent 299 euros ce smartphone qui est
assez équilibrée des performances qui
sont honnêtes des photos qui sont
corrects sans être complètement folle
une autonomie d'une journée un peu
standard et donc à côté multimédia qui
est correct donc je trouve bien mais
c'est pas le smartphone le plus exigeant
je sais pas vous ce que vous en pensez
que vous allez me dire tout ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire comment
vous trouvez ce smartphone est ce que
vous trouvez intéressant je sais plus où
il est il est là est ce que vous le
trouve intéressant mais je trouve que le
design est bien il n'y a rien de bien
neuf
vous avez les boutons de volume pour
l'allumer pour l'éteindre haut parleur
mono la prise jack micro usb ici ce côté
absolument rien sur le dessus votre
tiroir deux cartes sim
la petite encoche qui reste quand même
dans les tendances actuelles
le capteur d'empreintes digitales d'eau
qui est assez efficace c'est un
smartphone qu'efficace en faire trop
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bas
et puis est ce que vous pourriez vous
laisser tenter
comment vous trouvez sonore valve ait ni
vos bottes il vous botte pas là est ce
que vous attendez le haut norvins qui
sortira d'ici quelques jours d'ailleurs
vous en dit c'est dès maintenant vous
abonner pas ce que je vais vous emmener
à londres avec moi pour aller découvrir
et puis le testera un peu plus tard ce
rendez-vous dès demain vous embrasse
ciao
[Musique]